speaking of president trump he is
scheduled to appear in scranton
pennsylvania today not
far in fact from where joe biden spent
part of his childhood
in the meantime the president is
stirring up new controversy after
calling for a boycott
of goodyear tires a boycott he's calling
for because of the company's policy on
political speech in the workplace
democrats are saying
that the move could cost jobs at a time
when the country is already in an
economic crisis
paula reed is following all of this for
us and reports now from the white house
i'm not happy with goodyear because what
they're doing is playing politics
the president condemned the ohio-based
company and even said he would swap out
the goodyear tires on the presidential
limousine
known as the beast i would do that i
would swap him out based on what i heard
mr trump's comments come after goodyear
employees were told
political messages from both sides were
being banned
including maga attire cbs news pressed
the white house on why the president was
attacking an american company
so why is the president retaliating
against a private company for their
dress code and potentially jeopardizing
american jobs
goodyear needs to come out and clarify
their policy racial equality racial
justice that is okay but not political
speech as far as i'm concerned blue
lives matter is an equity issue there
in a statement goodyear said it has
always wholeheartedly supported both
equality and law enforcement and will
continue to do so
democratic ohio senator sherrod brown
but i do think it's despicable and
president united states
thinks it's appropriate to wake to call
for a boycott of the u.s company where
there are
thousands and thousands of american
workers
employed i'm signing today an absentee
ballot
meanwhile the trump campaign released
video of the president filling out his
own absentee ballot
even as he continues to rail against
some forms of mail-in voting
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
says he is confident about the post
office's ability to handle
all the people who will likely be voting
by mail in november
we're going to have a credible election
it's going to occur on november the 3rd
but house speaker nancy pelosi is
dubious about the post office's promise
to temporarily halt
changes to the service saying the
alleged pause is wholly insufficient
and does not reverse damage already
wreaked
pelosi says democrats still plan to vote
on saturday for an additional
25 billion dollars in funding for the
post office
while 90 house democrats are calling for
postmaster general louis dejoy to step
down
saying that his removal is necessary for
the quote health of our democracy
de joy is expected to face some tough
questions as he testifies before
congress tomorrow
and early next week anthony paula thank
you